[Music]
the walking dead has no shortage of bad
guys
big and small but who's the biggest
baddest antagonist of them all
we're here to find out by ranking every
single major walking dead villain from
the least
impressive to the most brutally fearsome
first introduced in season seven jadis
is the leader of a faction known as the
scavengers
rick approaches them in the hopes of
gaining more soldiers in his fight
against negan and the saviors
jadis is depicted as a curt cold leader
of a handful of loyal survivors
she lives in a junkyard where she often
makes art out of the items that are
discarded
and chooses to speak in broken english
still
alone you
[Music]
need us to save you although her
eccentricities make jadis whose real
name is later revealed to be an
irritating they're not the reason she
ranks as one of the worst villains on
the show
when push comes to shove jadis's move is
always to extort something out of the
people she
has power over when rick comes with his
hat in his hand
she demands some kind of tribute when
she agrees to fight alongside him
she eventually betrays the alexandrians
and joins the saviors
only to later betray them when the tide
of the battle shifts
in the end she makes one greedy choice
too many and her entire group is
massacred by the saviors at the behest
of simon
her time as a villain is marked by
perplexing character traits
and an inability to really impact the
outcome of the world
when gregory is introduced he seems like
an impressive figure
he's run the hilltop colony since the
beginning and by season 6
it stands as one of the few safe havens
left in the world
however as the world grows and alliances
start to form
it becomes clear that gregory is only a
peacetime leader
and a very average one at that when the
saviors first arrive
he's unable to put up much of a fight
and almost immediately rolls over
once rick comes around he realizes that
his people need some muscle
and agrees to help right up until rick
loses his first battle with the saviors
he then declares their deal null and
void after that
maggie gains popularity as a leader
among hilltop residents
prompting gregory to attempt to defect
to the saviors perhaps you've already
noticed the pattern here
gregory gives up at the drop of a hat
whenever things get real
he simply quits and joins the other team
bouncing back and forth between the good
guys and bad guys
and having little impact on either
faction you're really gonna stand there
and pretend you didn't try to sell us
out sell this place out
to the saviors i was working for the
side of sanity
i was working for peace hero or villain
a person in the world of the walking
dead has to make big moves that might
lead to conflict
even if he's no fighter maintaining
control is key
and gregory from the get-go never really
has control of anyone or anything
it's rare that a villainous group on the
walking dead has no distinct leader
but such is the case with the wolves the
wolves are a group of marauders active
in the washington dc
area who survive by raiding any living
people for supplies
then using their zombified bodies as
bait to attract more prey
they foster a sense of unease in the
area by marking areas they've hit
with the words wolves not far yet
theatrics don't end there
they carve a w into both their foreheads
and the foreheads of their victims
for all their style the wolves don't
last very long against rick's group
or even carol on her own in season 6
after teasing their presence in the area
for weeks they launch a full-on attack
on alexandria
in the end however their attack on
alexandria is nothing more than a
surprisingly toothless display of
intimidation
carol disguised as a wolf successfully
slaughters a number of them
and the alexandrians are able to repel
their forces
so much for the wolves ferocity you said
it right
don't ever be sorry all things
considered
gareth is actually a pretty savvy
villain not only does he lead a large
faction of people he manages to hatch a
pretty clever scheme that brings a lot
of unsuspecting victims into his web
after founding terminus as a safe haven
gary's good intentions are foiled by a
group of hostile survivors who briefly
take over
he manages to get the place back but
only by resorting to villainous tactics
following this gareth grows merciless
and turns his little beacon of hope
into a trap for people in the area who
hear radio broadcasts hailing terminus
as a sanctuary
in reality it's a meat factory for
cannibals it makes you feel any better
you taste much better than we thought
you would
the only reason gareth ranks so low on
this list is simply that his villainy
doesn't last
long in the face of rick grimes and his
survivors after gareth captures the
group
and attempts to slaughter them for meat
rick and company managed to escape
and take terminus out with everything he
built in ruins
gareth tracks them to a nearby church
and manages to capture bob
ultimately though his tracking amounts
to nothing as rick makes good on his
promise to kill him with a red handled
machete
gareth is neither the most cunning nor
the most threatening villain on the
walking dead but he does manage to build
something worthy of infamy
unfortunately his contribution to the
world ends there
dwight is an enormously complicated
villain however that complexity somewhat
diminishes his level of success as a bad
guy
his heart just isn't in it dwight is
introduced as someone who betrays
daryl's kindness on the road
after fleeing the saviors with his wife
and sister-in-law
eventually the family returns and negan
separates the wife from his wife and
burns half his face off with an eye in
for his desertion
after enduring this trauma and spending
a good portion of time in solitary
confinement
dwight emerges as one of negan's top
guys he's reintroduced to the survivors
after he mercilessly shoots denise
through the eye
and is part of the team that captures
the survivors before abraham and glenn
are executed by negan
basically dwight is an irredeemable
bastard at this point in the story
however his love for his wife keeps a
singular spark of humanity alive within
him
and eventually he makes the bold choice
to turn on negan and the saviors
and act as a mole for the alexandrians
i hate him i hate naked
for a time dwight is a pretty
captivating figure to watch
because it's genuinely unclear where his
loyalties lie
in the end he makes the tough call to do
the right thing and daryl spares his
life as a result
he's one of the walking dead's more
understated antagonist
and that makes him a relatively minor
figure on this list
but definitely not in the hearts of the
show's fans
while joan never leads a large group
like jadis gareth or the wolves
he gets major points for being a
seriously evil person
he's first introduced as the leader of a
very small group of marauders called the
claimers
they roll into a house that rick happens
to be hiding out in
and quickly demonstrate their depravity
rick manages to escape them
but not without killing a claimer while
tracking rick down for revenge
joe meets and befriends daryl and
explains his philosophy on leadership
joe manages to keep his small group in
line by issuing one major rule
anyone who claims something owns it by
right those who violate this rule are
punished with a beating
or worse the claims are a small faction
because joe deals with internal
conflicts
by straight up killing the person who is
at fault when joe catches up to rick
he threatens to kill daryl and assault
both michonne and carl
he genuinely gets one over on rick but
only briefly
because joe underestimates his
opponent's savagery rick
rips out joe's throat with his teeth
putting it into his misguided world view
right then and there oh part i never
looked at like that
seems to me like things are probably
starting to fall together
at least for guys like us sometimes the
scariest villains are the ones who are
convinced they're the good guy
when dawn is introduced she's several
years into the apocalypse but is still
holding out hope for a government rescue
dawn presides over a hospital that she
and a handful of other survivors
cops and physicians have turned into a
very tense safe haven
with resources dwindling don allows all
sorts of horrific crimes
all in the name of keeping their way of
life going until a government rescue
arrives
this is as the audience knows a long
wait for a train that simply isn't
coming
try to look at the good we're doing
hard as it was we saved jones life
trevit's life we saved your life
when beth arrives as a patient she's
given a crash course in dawn's deeply
and profoundly misguided way of leading
when beth befriends a guy named noah
they hatch a plan that half fails
and only allows him to escape while beth
stays back and faces the consequences
from one of dawn's men
it becomes clear that dawn is losing
control prompting her to do something
drastic
when best group comes to negotiate a
trade for beth and carol who has been
injured and brought to the hospital
don tries to prove herself by demanding
they get noah back as well
driven to madness by her brief time with
dawn beth stabs her
don reflexively shoots her and is
immediately shot dead by daryl
the governor aka philip blake deserves
high honors for being the walking dead's
very first through and through
honest-to-god villain prior to his
arrival the worst threat to humanity is
merle dixon
when daryl's brother is finally seen
again after more than a year
he's following the governor's orders
which really says something about the
company blake keeps when the governor is
introduced
he is revealed to have accomplished what
rick has failed to do he has created a
working society within the zombie
apocalypse
while the show has since seen a bevy of
strongholds from both good guys and bad
guys take shape
the governor is the first to do it it's
not exactly a success however
things get very dystopian there only
about a year or two out from the onset
of the apocalypse
you know all about me and i know all
about you i don't care about any of that
we're here to move forward
what really makes the governor a top
villain isn't his leadership
but his madness there's just no telling
how he'll wield his power from moment to
moment
even his demise comes as a result of his
own lunacy upset over the loss of
woodbury and its people's assimilation
into the prison
he drives a tank through one of the only
safe havens left in the world
and dies trying to exact physical
revenge on rick grimes
alpha is curt cold and has no time for
any weakness in her ranks
she survives by leading a group called
the whisperers who live among the
walkers and even managed to control
their movements through herding tactics
she is the first to recognize that the
walkers are the weapon
that brought humanity to its knees
making even the mightiest people and
institutions fall
so when she encounters rick's group she
has very little time for their
emotionality and moral compunctions
however since they've captured her only
daughter lydia she has no choice but to
roll through them with brutal vengeance
the war with the whisperers becomes one
of the strongest conflicts in the series
though beta alpha's right hand man does
most of the heavy lifting
she's the one who herds enough walkers
to basically wield this world's
equivalent of a nuke alpha is one of
very few villains on the walking dead
who doesn't underestimate her opponents
and that counts for everything
they all follow me by choice because i
make them strong
even people with a cursory understanding
of the walking dead
know that negan is the greatest
antagonist the show has ever seen
although he spends a majority of his
time on the show on a path to redemption
he wouldn't even be alive if it wasn't
for his ruthlessness
when negan is first introduced he
infamously kills
abraham and glenn for no other reason
than to demonstrate his power
negan has a twisted way of always making
good decisions he views people as a
resource
this means he's not a loose cannon
homicidal maniac like the governor or
joe
his conflicts are calculated and he
knows who will live or die before he
even begins a conversation
when it comes to leadership he defers
from jadis and don
in that he knows success lies not in
keeping people going but in giving them
an opportunity to thrive
hence the sanctuary's point system let
mark's face
be a daily reminder to him and everyone
else
that the rules matter
however the main thing that makes negan
such an effective villain
is the fact that he's capable unlike
gregory or don
when push comes to shove negan can fend
for himself
he boasts the smartest and most broken
mind in any room
and is enormously capable of exerting
his will on the people around him
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite television shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]